Nói Tau đến rất to kéo dài từ năm giờ đến bây giờ xả ngay bán bói thằng sau,
tàn nhiều khu vật của khoảng ninh, lượng mưa đo được tại các khu vật hà lông
cầm phà từ 1 trong 2 lâm để 1 trong 3 mươi mê mẹh khiển nhiều chuyển phổ ổ tại các nô thi
đường rao thông bị nập tổng cục bộ, các phường hà lông, thông gái, cao xanh, khá khán hà lâm,
điều xất hiện các điểm ngập tổng từ khu vẻ 2 để khu vẻ nâm mẹh, anh hưởng đến rao thông và trạm vào một số nhà rân.
Chưa và chờ vói tần sau tại khoảng ninh vẫn sự bảo kết tục có mưa vừa đến mưa tò đến rất tò,
ở nhiều khu vật lần mưa kéo dài điểm 2 trong bây, lượng mưa phổ biến từ tạm mưa ý đến 1 trong bây mươi mê mê mê
còn nơi trên 2 trong 1 mươi mê mê, mùi cơ xuất hiện giống nập tổng, lúc quát và xa lợd đất.
Như khu vật khá lông, khu vực mong cái, cùng cá sả mình liệu, bà trẻ, tin in và một số khu vật m intoi, phàn xong, sối.
Bình cảnh quyết cơ nập lùd gây tắc nè dấu thông cục bộ ở một số tuyên phố, đến đường, mưa lướn còn có thể gây sạp lợ tạm mại thải,
hôm lò, với thiệt 2 cho các hoạt động sản xuất kinh giói, trước dịch biến phúc tạm vào thề tiếp các cơ quan trích năng để phương,
ứng trước khoảng trống, quên cáng ui ra nướng cao kẻng giá, chủ động kìm trà lợd, ra cố tài sản,
hạn chế gi chuyển khi mưa lộn và tựt lối không qua các khu vực nập sau lúc trả sét để mạo đàn ăn toàn.